the Joe Rogan experience uber dicey yeah
didn't they do that with an African man
in the Bronx Zoo and like the turn of
the century they put an African man in
the Bronx yes they did yeah they have an
African man I believe it was the Bronx
Zoo oh and like the 1800s or the early
1900s II hate me yep Otto Benga what
year was it 1906 oh wow yeah it's they
had them in the zoom it's insane
look at that Wow dudes in the zoo yeah
well you know what man people were just
figuring life out back then
right right this is the reality of human
beings is that we have not been alive
that long and we have not been civilized
in terms of how we view the world today
with inclusivity and objectivity and
care and you know kindness towards
others like this compassion and altruism
this is on a global scale this is fairly
recent yeah we're figuring things out as
we go I mean the history is a perfect it
can show you how we've progressed yeah
it's a document documentation of how we
progressed but yet still that was 50
years after slavery yeah right that's
crazy yeah 40 45 years after slavery
what the [ __ ] guys so Bronx Zoo you know
speaking in our like weird cryptid realm
reminded me of something so get this
chupacabra has been attributed to the
possibility that there are thylacine in
North America and here's what supports
that there is documented proof that
however many years ago I don't remember
the dates there were two breeding pair
of thylacine bound for the Bronx Zoo and
they boat crashed into the shore and
most of the animals escaped including
the two breeding pair of thylacine fast
forward 10 15 years you start having
these Chupacabra sightings pop up in the
Northeast and these animals were adapted
to living in Tasmania which is a pretty
similar climate to the North America and
northeast and so there's people that
have kind of drawn these parallels and
said oh the chupacabra that we've
reported running around you know the
United States is actually a tiny remnant
population of these thylacine
were brought here for the Bronx Zoo that
escaped what you buy into this no no
right but it sounds it's an amazing
story had me if you said yes of stuff
you talked about if someone could get
one for the Bronx Zoo then what a rich
person have been able to buy one like a
rich guy in Texas for instance a
thylacine been able to purchase one
private yeah you can probably get one
today yeah go to Bubba's house but
especially back then there were no like
import-export laws about wildlife you
know you could just bring in whatever
you liked if you had money you know
what's to say everybody was in a race to
collect stuff for zoos and museums like
what's to say somebody didn't bring some
in Texas and there exotics it's so
string I mean I had a bit about it in my
act in 2016 my Netflix special that
there's more tigers in captivity in
Texas and private collections then there
are and all of the wild of the world
isn't that insane just Texas and that's
like in guy's living rooms in you know a
cage yeehaw
yeah phase a mistake yeah it's not it is
nuts
[Applause]